The other two kinds of constraints are pre and post conditions.
These are used for expressing precisely what it means to use an operation
that belongs to some class. The key words here are P-R-E for pre, and post for
post. In a given, constraint, you can have one of these or both of these.
Or you could have two constraints, one with pre and one with post in it.
Preconditions says the circumstances under which it's allowed that a particular
operation to take place. Post conditions says what is the results of executing
this particular operation. Typically that means, what's the relationship of
the return value to the input parameters? However in an object-oriented language
it might also mean what are the effects on any attributes of
the classes that take place because of the operation has been invoked.